I want to make sure every business owner
in my community has the funding they
need to pull off the brave thing they're
doing with their business. And many of
them are already there. They don't need
the funding anymore. But most aren't.
Six out of 10 aren't. And I want to make
sure if and when they need it, they've
got a guy right here locally. They don't
have to work with some stranger on a
telemarketing line. That's what I
believe. And I need some more brokers
right here in my town. I want to train
them, show them how, and teach them how
to take care of those clients. I want to
build a small team and then grow it and
grow it and grow it from there. That's
what I want to do. You want to help me
do it?